Wesley Kevin congratulations you Smiths
are in the third and final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to recreate this
iconic weapon from history
[Music]
that is the PIRA
today we're going to be pre-testing the
PIRA
so probably the most identifiable piece
of this sword is that the PIRA has a
very unique handle it's got an extension
that comes out this way I was like
what's the purpose of that now the first
I'm thinking is that a functional piece
maybe to form as a guard to protect the
forearm no it's a piece of wood that if
you cut through it will cut all the way
through
the period is really by the contract who
are by the coastal Waters and that by
adding that Dimension to that handle it
actually is almost like paying homage to
their seafaring way of life so it's not
necessarily always functional as I
thought that would be the pier is the
favorite weapon of the yakin tribe of
the South Philippines it functions as an
all-purpose tool a lethal blade and a
cultural symbol given to those leaving
their Village as a reminder of where
they came from
one of the most prominent features is
its flared pommel which is inspired by
the boat paddles these seafaring people
depended on a thick Blade the weapon is
built for chopping and is capable of
inflicting deep gashes with each slash
the deadly weapon has a fearful
reputation among natives as the weapon
of choice for decapitating enemies
[Music]
we tested the fira on a wild boar a wild
boar skin is very tough a lot of hair in
there
foreign
I can tell by the design if it's a
slasher and a chopper I can tell if by
the way you're holding on to the handle
which doesn't have a guard so it's not
made for thrusting it's more for
slashing and chopping
then you look at all the extensions of
the blade how do I move around it so
that I'm able to freely use it
effectively that's very important
in its function it shouldn't be too
close to the arm to where it catches
your arm and you're not able to move or
it starts scratching you or if it starts
snagging in your clothing as you're
wielding the weapon
one of the coolest thing about this
weapon is that it's something that I'm
familiar with from my culture so seeing
it hearing about it now I get to feel it
actually wheeled one and then test it
that's awesome
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
four days
good luck man good luck on YouTube
my name is Kevin Burgess I'm 20 years
old I've been making knives for about
three years I hope to eventually achieve
the rank of master smith and to be
mildly respected among any group I walk
into
only mildly though I need to keep them
modest I'm going to be making Damascus
it looks pretty shows a bit of skill and
I'm hoping that this Damascus will beat
out a model of Steel blade okay and into
the forge we go I'm using 1084 and 1520
for my billets I got my handle shaped
and I even gotten a chance to start
carving on it
today's agenda is he treats hopefully
I'll be able to keep it straight
I pull it out of the quench there's a
little bit of warp in it it's pulling
off to the right
uh son of a gun so I decide to do a
temper and put it into a jig that will
straighten it out
I take out the blade and the entire
blades crack from Edge to spine me me me
this Plate's done
yeah
it must have been under so much stress
that it just snapped it's time to time
to get forging again Plan B is to just
go on to Mono steel I don't have time to
make another build of Damascus I'm gonna
fit up the guard from there I just go on
to my handle just you know sanding
everything making it all nice and smooth
I do the edge one final time and with
that I'm done
I can't wait to see what doug does with
it
my name is Wesley Knoll I got interested
in blacksmithing because I thought it
looked cool I have relatives from a very
long time ago that were blacksmiths
winning this money would actually allow
me to get a little bit closer to my
dream of owning my own Forge
so I decide to go with a Damascus
pattern I am going to use 1084 and 15
and 20.
I'm going to make a handful of small
billets that I will eventually combine
one giant fillet would be really hard to
work with so I want to make the smaller
billets to make them manageable
I need to clean up the faces that will
be touching simply because it'll help
for a cleaner weld I need to get this
thing shaped I start to work in my swell
but as I continue to stretch my metal
I'm noticing that it is getting
dangerously thin
I stick it back to kind of straighten
everything out
and I just watch it
lean
it it won't survive the quench
it just won't so two and a half days in
I'm starting over with a monoceal I
grabbed my bar at 5160 and into the
forge it goes
having to start over halfway through day
three is
it sucks I have to make a PIRA in
basically one day I got the profile of
the blade forged out I need to finish
grinding I need to Quench and I have to
put the handle together
pull it out and it's warped just a
little bit at this point I'll take it I
start to work on my handle this handle
is hard to do because the tail is coming
off at a really weird angle
the fitting of it everything takes time
that I do not have right now
I don't have the luxury to add pins but
I've got to get it stuck together so
five minute epoxy it is
I'm done there's nothing else I can do
I'm out of time I'm not turning in
exactly what I wanted to turn in but
there's no quitting me and because of
that I have a finished PIRA Nate Smith's
welcome to the kill test
your peers look very interesting now
it's time to find out how lethal they
are to find it out I will take your
pillars and deliver some slashes and
hacks on this for carcass
Kevin you're up first you ready for this
oh yeah let's do this
[Music]
two
yeah
all right Kevin let's talk about your
Pita here you sir have captured the
spirit of what this weapon is all about
the flare that you have they're actually
really allows me to really get a good
grip
you have a forward weight but it's
perfectly placed right where The Sweet
Spot is making every cut very deep
nothing wrong with the edge it's still
laser Sharp
and it will heal
laughs
All Right Wesley ready to chop some pork
ready as I'll ever be all right let's do
it
uh this is a big pig
and all I can think is my handle is
gonna bust into
I don't see a pin here is there any
mechanical connection at all that's
holding this
right in there I didn't have time
I understand
there's no mechanical connection here
usually when they whisper this is a
really bad sign
I don't want to hold back holding back
is that a fair way to test it right of
course
Wesley this is always tough for any
Smith we understand that the problems
you had at home kind of bit you when it
came to finishing that blade right now
the handle of your blade is held in
place by Glue there are no mechanical
Connections in the handle a forged and
fire Champion make sure that their
weapon is made to withstand pushing a
blade to the absolute limits of what's
possible and unfortunately we can't
engage your weapon like that for that
reason please exit the forge come on
forward
thank you to push as hard as I felt like
I pushed and get here and not have it
tested
it's a bummer good job I understand why
and I agree but I mean
kind of would have been cool to at least
see it bust halfway through big
but I was still able to at least present
something to them to show them that I
don't quit I don't give up and I am very
proud of myself for that
Kevin congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job my friend
you did fantastic work you deserve it
come over here and Shake our hands
me you know here I am I'm standing
champion of Fortune flyer I would have
liked to have gotten through all three
tests but I've proven that you know not
only do I make the stuff I make but I
make it pretty damn good as well I just
want force and Fire
[Laughter]